elle a jamais montré de signes de
méchanceté ou de signe caractériel après
de problème où elle a elle a eu un
caractère de diva où elle s'est vraiment
emportée elle a montré que c'était
quelqu'un qui mord non plus hein
à l'hôtel de fou moi j'ai déjà eu des
des stars parce que ça c'est intéressant
est-ce que vous avez du destin dans
l'hôtel qui parce que je sais qu'il y a
plein de stars dans cet hôtel
franchement ça je parle dans cet hôtel
là mais là pour le coup c'était pas dans
cet hôtel là parce que depuis même dans
les hôtels vous allez travailler est-ce
que vous avez des demandes de foudre
extrêmement particulière
j'ai une personne un jour qui m'a dit
j'aimerais avoir 1000 roses et un paquet
cadeau à l'intérieur vous mettez tel et
tel sex toys
et vous avez acheté vous-même les
sextoys ah bah oui en fait on se doit
d'aller acheter telle marque telle
référence et les poser à tel endroit
comme votre demande
après ça peut être des demandes du style
je ne viens pas avec ma femme mais je
viens avec
[Rires]
je viens avec une escorte d'accord on va
arriver avec des escortes et en fait il
y en a pas qu'une quoi non alors il y a
des mecs ils avaient plusieurs escorts
dans la chambre
préciser que c'est pas moi ce que vous
pouvez préciser que c'est pas moi non
plus et c'est pas Guillaume non plus
c'est que
j'étais sympa à l'hôtel non j'ai très
sympa vos petites habitudes le matin
très facilement
c'est un Perrier avec une tranche de
citron et si je dis pas de bêtises c'est
un pain au raisin
j'adore mais on s'était bien aimé et il
le prend en chambre il le fait où
il descend il t'emmerde c'est pour
savoir
il descend et dites-nous il y a eu quoi
comme il y a eu quoi comme truc
une star qui était insupportable sans la
cité sans dire non j'ai déjà eu une
personnalité qui a été très exigeante
donc là on peut parler vraiment d'une
personne diva qui a été très exigeante
en plus que vous connaissez très très
bien je ne citerai pas le nom mais allez
on va lancer un manuel
[Applaudissements]
on va revoir le geste de la Zara
regardez regardez ce qu'elle avait
regardé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est mon père c'est pas le téléphone là
alors la personne dont parle parce que
on aime bien
la personne
en fait il est où là
vous foutez quoi ouais mais j'ai pas
commandé ça c'est de la merde c'est
dégueulasse
c'était très compliqué c'est très très
dur très dur de gérer cette personne
vous devez voir des trucs de fou dans
les hôtels non je vois beaucoup de
choses particulières farfelues je
travaille dans un hôtel qui est basé sur
le signe alors c'est pas un hôtel de
charme c'est basé sur le signe de
l'amour et de la
destination amoureuse et donc
du coup
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il y a jamais eu en fait ce qui a été
dit hier soir parce que j'ai regardé
l'émission et en fait j'étais
extrêmement choqué de ce qu'il y avait
plus être dit parce que c'est vraiment
tout l'inverse de ce qu'on peut de ce
qu'on peut voir je vais donner une
anecdote toute bête on a été dans un
hôtel un après-midi enfin en début de
soirée avec la Zara et d'autres
personnes qui sont moins connues elle
est extrêmement timide c'est quelqu'un
qui sort en
elle est très nature peinture en fait
c'est à dire que ce que vous voyez en
fait à la télé c'est totalement
l'inverse de ce qu'elle représente
aujourd'hui il faut aussi se dire que
elle a un rôle c'est un personnage c'est
vous la voyez comment ça s'appelle
Fatima
elle avait dans le magasin
elle a repris
mais ce que vous voyez là en fait n'a
strictement rien à voir avec la personne
qu'elle est moi la fatigue que je
connais c'est une personne totalement
naturel peinture et qui ne fait pas de
qui veut pas de sac Louis Vuitton Sac
Chanel elle est sortie avec un bonnet
enfin elle sort enfin voilà
plus que simple en fait est-ce que nous
a parlé depuis qu'elle est dans
l'aventure de l'Eurovision est-ce
qu'elle vous a dit ce que ça leur pensée
si elle était contente depuis depuis
j'ai pas vraiment de nouvelles cependant
je veux les croiser parce qu'on a posé
très à côté on est presque voisine et je
l'ai croisé
un peu des pieds à faire comme ça
[Rires]
bien sûr
du plateau
[Rires]
est-ce qu'elle elle marche bien les
armes parce que je la connaissais pas
moi le réseau la Zara elle a été connue
pour faire un duo avec Niro printemps
blancs qui est sorti en 2015 il me
semble
par la suite après la sortie en album
elle a pas été extrêmement connue
[Musique]
tu connais déjà ta suite donc
vous disiez au départ qu'il y avait eu
d'abord un accrochage qui fait que vous
avez
on lui fait pas c'était de notre côté en
fait c'est à dire qu'on ne lui avait pas
préparé la chambre à temps chose que je
peux comprendre avec du décalage
avec du décalage horaire
dans la journée pour
[Musique]
toi tu vas pouvoir faire deux heures
chez toi dans la journée tu vas voir
même trois tu vas de 18h40 à 21h15 tu
vois pas mal de temps et donc ouais vous
avez pas préparé la chambre tout seul il
a rien dit voilà après ce qui est normal
on rentre on a du décalage horaire
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit moi je sais que
je sais l'hôtel où vous étiez parce que
j'en avais entendu parler la chambre
n'était pas prête elle a fait comme ça
évidemment
mais la chambre je vais c'est parti elle
est partie s'asseoir elle a pris son
ordinateur elle a dit bon bah ok il y a
pas de souci
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a des natures
parce que cette histoire ça fait une
histoire de fou il y a Stéphane Bern qui
s'est confié sur Europe 1 sur ce doigt
d'honneur sur comment il l'avait vécu et
sur la réunion de crise qui a été
organisé juste après ouais ils se
prennent la tête de fou
eux là-bas il ferme rideau d'honneur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on se voit concernant le doigt d'honneur
on a parlé d'un tous Patrick t'as vu sur
la cantine de France Télé tu as entendu
parler du tout
paraît-il que la Sarah aurait fait un
tour à l'Europe entière écoute c'est
vraiment sa rue dans les brocards non
mais c'est d'ailleurs vous étiez vous
une histoire comme ça c'est chaud ou pas
parce que tu vois c'est bien que tu sois
là ce soir c'est chaud non mais c'est
très chaud c'est une émission qui
regardait par plus de 190 millions
pardon
90 millions de téléspectateurs dans le
monde et en fait ce rôle est vachement
important et plus important qu'on le
pense parce que vous êtes vraiment le
représentant de la France vous êtes
représentant du pays à ça au niveau de
tous les pays alors déjà bon c'est comme
le fromage
on sait que c'est un mode géopolitique
les pays s'envoient les points entre eux
c'est divertissement de tout les chaînes
de France Télévisions et quand j'ai fait
l'Eurovision c'est faut vraiment pas con
je croyais mais je crois qu'on essaie
matador non non
Jesse matador
déjà à l'époque était un scandale parce
que les gens avaient très mal réagi au
fait que ce soit noir et présente la
France à l'Euromillions
pour tout le monde c'est gênant pour
France Télévision c'est gênant parce que
ça a été un choix ça a été un choix de
la directrice des divertissements de
France 2 direct ils ont pas fait de
casting donc c'est vachement emmerdant
c'est pas une situation
qui est une proie qui a une
problématique puisque elle commence à
dire que c'est un geste culturel donc je
sais pas qui elle emmène dans son geste
culturel je suis désolé donc c'est c'est
pas le refaire parce que
se taire et France Télévisions aussi
s'ils avaient fait une réunion de crise
auraient dû lui dire blackout on arrête
de parler on essaye de laisser passer le
truc et de passer à autre chose ça je
trouve qu'elle se défend très mal en
plus derrière donc le 12 ça ne passe pas
ça ne serait pas passé vous auriez fait
quoi vous êtes le Patron là de France
vous faites quoi voilà il se passe ça
votre directrice de divertissement fait
qu'est-ce que vous faites dites la
vérité je pense qu'à la fin mon choix
parce que c'est une fille très
talentueuse Lazare je suis désolé ça a
un talent monstrueux et c'est vraiment
elle aurait pu enfin
la star montante de l'autre côté je ne
l'aurais jamais choisi parce que quand
vous entendez parler de la Zara tout le
monde tout le monde sait tout le monde
connaît la difficulté à gérer quelqu'un
comme les arts et d'ailleurs je crois
que vous avez reçu pharaon hier où vous
avez eu voilà en 4e
on arrive déjà pas à gérer l'artiste
imaginez ce que ça peut être quand elle
est sur un plateau de télévision et
qu'elle a une telle responsabilité donc
je leur ai pas choisi à titre personnel
non mais vous faites quoi avec le doigt
vous êtes le patron de la directrice
divertissement vous étiez pas trop
délire donc vous avez je vous aviez
quelqu'un je suis hyper malade mais
c'est pas vous vous étiez au-dessus par
rapport à l'artiste
c'est Nicolas on le sait tu étais patron
transversal de tout à France
téléviseurs qui fait ça tu fais quoi bah
pour rien la pauvre donc tu fais quoi
mais je la reçois en disant vous
auriez pu gérer
c'est c'est le bordel parce qu'en plus
tout de suite vous regardez sur Twitter
il commence à avoir des problèmes de
religion on commence à dire de la France
alors ça devient le bordel donc c'est
tout mais en l'occurrence vous avez pas
viré la directrice des divertissement
parce que elle a choisi lazarella là-bas
je veux dire
à côté non à côté de la tête quand elle
voit le truc non
c'est pas grave
non non elle a pas pu parce qu'elle le
fait un peu elle a en fait elle a son
brushing qui cache Bluetooth
il y avait les Italiens avec on a cru
que c'était
passé on va pas reprocher au comité
italien d'avoir choisi un groupe de rock
hyper rebelle si elle avait on dirait
qu'elle est géniale c'est une fille au
moment elle le fait au moment en fait ou
c'est le vote du public je crois que
c'est le vote du public en plus c'est
c'est pas le moment choisi autant
qu'elle on arrive de toute façon il faut
pas le faire mais quand elle le fait au
moment des points on sait que les points
de toute façon la France ne peut pas
gagner c'est impossible c'est bien de
dire
définitivement les points ils sont
donnés entre les gens bien sûr
ça a changé il y a un jury la France
elle a failli gagner il y a 2 ans
Hugo on gagnera jamais
un truc qu'on ne souhaite pas est-ce que
ça coûte une blinde à 50 millions au
niveau de l'organisation c'est c'est
personne n'en veut la voir alors épanou
alors attention parce que de ce côté
c'est l'Eurovision c'est comment vous
expliquer c'est vraiment le truc du pays
quoi la Suède arrête de vivre au moment
de l'Eurovision c'est là-bas c'est c'est
c'est énorme l'Eurovision c'est le chaud
le chaud énorme comment juste amis euh
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu d'autres
gens ici qui était dans l'hôtel ça va
bien
apparemment
là autour de la table une seule une
seule donc c'est une fille
mais ce que je peux juste revenir sur ce
que Nicolas pernica fait
vous êtes en train de dire que elle est
difficile à gérer parce que on a entendu
un vocal hier de Sébastien Farran qui
est son ex manager donc du coup elle est
difficile à gérer parce que on a entendu
dire que il est allé au Québec il s'est
il est parti là-bas et elle lui aide
soi-disant dit j'aimerais un sac Louis
Vuitton en 5 Chanel
donc pour ça il est difficile à gérer
c'est ça
j'aurais pas pris ce risque connaissant
cette personnalité après comme dis Cyril
et je crois qu'il a raison c'est bien
aussi d'avoir des gens un peu singuliers
qui ont de ce que j'ai dit le seul truc
qui a non mais sur le fait de la
personnalité
les vrais stars ont plutôt de la
personnalité le doigt d'honneur il est
malvenu